how would you describe your ideal
Southern gentleman Bonner that's got our
hurt but I feel you girl nor money
throwing some shade and her two dancing
partners tonight Val and Allen but
before we get into how that trio is
gonna work out I asked the fifth harmony
star if she's even healthy enough to
dance okay how's your back it's getting
better honestly yeah I can actually get
out of it by myself now my mom had to
help me oh yeah my medicine is really
kicking in and I'm killing it actually
doesn't know where she is but she's
feeling better no money maybe on the
mend from a back and hip strain but
tonight she'll have to pull double duty
in the ballroom performing two full
length dances have you had to modify
anything that you've done choreography
wise because of her injury do even
different very little I mean last week
just because I'm super stubborn and
she's really stubborn in work and you
know and that always kind of lingers on
the line of big neck stupidity a little
bit we're not changing anything this
week we were there as Val normanni
practiced their first number of the
night a contemporary routine later our
favorite fill-in Pro Alan Burstyn will
join the duo for a trio dance is the
same true two's company three's a crowd
cuz now you got out right oh no not like
I know what I'm saying
he's no it's good it's she loves him she
loves a lot of people it's amazing the
three of us have a great chemistry in a
room and it's gonna be a great number of
really fun and and I I you know you're
welcome Alan for the spotlight
enjoy
[Music]